[Music]
could not buy the dominant hell
each tafseer escaped slaves prison so I
hope a dialogue with the Commission's
president in jean-claude Yuka
but the minister president in the
slanders but miltenberg with Fred
Kretchman young came and talked about no
no in Sigmund with inside this making
for meows conditional to the goose
bottom as well tunics yoga method is a
stop Martin Hong two-inch - London after
Minister fear your seats
seongmo Juncker president I hope is
coming soon say get a minister president
benefit Kretchman theater minister
Minister face it sooner hope angling
height indeed wolf he starts 1850
village after any hats it's become
showing the sea isn't as manic or
Sephora's it because in so different
my MA sdcc are now safe secure here as
distance wise men--who mission fatigue
in Kraft cotton but for I mean it's
beautifully shot sumptuous the gun would
fit to an Impala chin Suzanne's loss is
not junior dimension of this incontinent
mushiya the sputum giggling at home
within a Janka Oh me chinga Kretchman
commands am to debauch ian debated
zukunft go pass by actually i was for on
such question about furniture breaking
say I get Commission's president Juncker
Saiga the minister was encouragement not
much heads become this is big shoe
industry doesn't recommend hi book
it's doable I'll conduct and discus on
Mann's mahadji scindia we fill the
analyze tab so this type of assessment
ask a warden I find an aussie upon and
she went to the border with me and for
my friend from Japan it was unimaginable
that there is no border
she was really hopping back and forth
between France and Germany insane
Germany France Germany France and she's
loved it I was born in 84 and I grew up
close the French border and when that
opened my eyes we have to be more aware
of the fact how privileged we are living
in the Europe that we have today Europe
the European Union with the Europe with
the Schengen area open borders
everywhere please never forget about
that it is not self-evident it is not a
matter of fact it is unique in the world
despite all the challenges the European
Union is the biggest Peace Project that
this continent has ever seen
[Applause]
this is not only a political union which
of course has scope for improvement but
it is community of values humanistic
values that we tend to pass on our
continent esses seen so much hardship so
many was and I underlined it as a young
person if the European Union this Peace
Project is the best that ever happened
to us and we need the European Union and
the European Union needs us and our
support for that reason we should not
trust those who want to have simple
solutions who offer over these simple
solutions and right populist
nationalists with their populism and
their talk and they're limited horizons
but also locally and also in their
mindsets it's a great privilege be
living in the European Union but it is
at the same time a big responsibility we
should defend our values and at times of
big challenges we need more together
nice ladies and gentlemen instead of
against this and that's also true for
Freiburg that's not only because of the
geographical situation in the dry
country three country region you go to
elseis and you can even take your bike
and go there it where it's nice enough
you can take the high-speed train to gvd
to go to Paris we're in a wonderful open
cosmopolitan city we are visiting our
friends and neighbors without visa
without border controls it's up to us to
decide on which side of the Rhine we
intend to live over it's a great
privilege and please bear that in mind
an impressive example ladies gentlemen
is also the cooperation of the regional
universities five universities
stretching along the Upper Rhine from
three countries joined forces
they call themselves you Corps a true
European campus is what they intend to
form cross-border studies without any
red tie between Strasbourg mill whose
cars Luke Freiburg and puzzle it means
to commute from one place to the other
but also having an exchange we need
mobility to do so functioning public
transport and this brings together young
people and we should not be worried
about the European Union if we succeed
doing that and now focusing on Freiburg
a wonderful region one of the most
important topics is and target sees that
railway line between us and our
neighboring city Kalmar should be
revived again it is a very ambitious
project and actors on both sides have
been joining forces making it come true
for a long time mr. young president of
the Commission and also Prime Minister
Kretchman and also mr. Voyles please
support this railway line but also the
European campus which we want to really
progress and advance I hope these
examples show you Missy Anka
that you've taken the right choice a
good choice Freiburg is the right City
for the thousands European citizens
dialogue we are very very proud that you
chose Freiburg for that we're grateful
that thousands citizens dialogue takes
place in our wonderful city of Freiburg
please let me underline once again a
warm welcome in this three country
region we're happy having you here
tonight
[Applause]
Yatta Yatta liebe Commission's president
of the commission is include Prime
Minister watchman Lord Mayor horn
citizens I'd also like to extend a warm
welcome to all of you here in Freiburg
together would like to talk about the
future of the European Union citizens
dialogue that is the format of tonight's
event the citizen psylocke is part of
the big European dialogue of the federal
government of the federal state of
baden-württemberg Europe is much too
important to us to leave it to the
populace in a row it's really bad mouth
it we want to develop a Europe bottom up
that is our political mandate that's why
we're here tonight
[Applause]
let's create the foundation for a new
light build Europe from the point of
view under the aspect of
baden-württemberg this light bill that
is our contribution to the debate about
the further development of the European
Union a dialogue that we have everywhere
in the European Union today also in
Brussels the Lord Mayor was really
putting it in charming words Freiburg is
the very city the perfect City for such
a dialogue the Upper Rhine area is
European country so to speak European
integration is not theory in this area
but lived practice this is where the
idea of the European University is not
just a vision
it is Europe and it is Europe has lived
Europe we are convinced Europeans and we
want to fill that Europe with life
[Applause]
the wishes worries that people associate
with a European Union can be looked at
as if they were shown under a magnifying
glass so the perfect place for citizens
to talk about our Europe we Europeans
for us let me give you an idea of how we
could change perspective that at least
most of us next year there will be
elections to the European Parliament
that was born in 2001 will for the first
time be allowed to vote these are young
people who during the terrorist attacks
on 9/11 were hardly born young people
who only know a divided Europe from
history books they've never used a
different currency than the Euro and
when the European Union Eastern
enlargement happened they were just
three years old for these young people
the European Union is not a question
mark but it is part of their identities
we know from surveys that the vast
majority of the young people are very
much in favor of the European Union why
because of peace freedom and prosperity
although it may seem sometimes as if
this had become a matter of fact that
Europe to fight for it as a peace
community is worth it for us as
convinced Europeans
[Applause]
for the synth ST practition huh these
practical questions of our daily life
traveling without borders without having
to change a currency international
roaming standards and the same is also
true for your passenger rights
pro-european discussing that it's not
difficult at all
with only have to do so on a more
intensified basis at the same time it's
true not everybody who criticizes Europe
is against Europe because the European
Union can improve especially you
wouldn't focusing on its strengths to
present when you took office you said
that a big things can be into big things
and small things and small things for
the big things a lot of things have to
be done protecting a dx0 borders except
in immigrants into European Union
refugees zeppelins eurozone protection
law and or in Europe and also the
challenges in connection with
digitization a European Union dealing
with all these big things offers enough
room for manoeuvre to its municipalities
to deal with local matters sometimes
Brussels seems very far away from
Stuttgart or Firebug
so mr. president a big thank you to you
that you openly initiated the white book
process and started white paper process
and laid the foundation for a large
process Europe's future
it's the perseverance of the parliaments
of the public at large in all parts of
society also on the roads that's it
shock people shook them awake then you
wanted to go into the roads and really
fight in favor of Europe and that is
something that has to be something that
we have to know if instead of
bad-mouthing Europe for to feel and
steamin on my noggin hub we shouldn't be
worried about too many different voices
we should try to be afraid of being too
indifferent against things we need
lively debates for Europe's future all
of us should participate and contributed
with know-how with heart and passion is
convinced Europeans thank you so much
[Applause]
yeah mine a dominant hand finding
fatigue whose water hair hung on the
wolf yeah
this could be unavoidable well thank you
so much mr. wolf mr. hunt for those warm
words of welcome we are not just live
here in the concert house but we're also
on the livestream of the European Union
many people from all over Europe are
listening today and later on the SWR
broadcaster is also going into linked-in
okay so let me say a few words on what
we're planning to do with you tonight as
part of this event you have already
noticed probably that there are two
different intentions with that we have
with this event we have the European
Commission prevent present but also the
government of this state and it's about
the future of Europe it's about letting
as many people as possible participate
in this discussion and this discussion
is part of a larger European citizens
dialogue of the state government that
has been going on for almost a year
there have been various events and
formats and various forms of
participation and one of those was in
this afternoon a workshop of randomly
selected citizens and we are going to
include the result of that workshop in
today's programme at the same time as we
have heard this event is the 1,000
citizens forum of the European Union
since we started that since they started
the program in 2015 so this is about
finding new goals for the community for
the Union and the state wants to
contribute its own light built its own
model to this discussion until the
beginning of next year
now the protagonists of tonight I don't
think I have to introduce them at links
jean-claude juncker well he was almost
there for the birth of the European
Union you could say he's been around for
decades almost since the foundation of
the European Union and different offices
and different roles be the Minister of
Finance of his country be the prime
minister of Luxembourg no later on as
the head of the Euro group in very
turbulent times I have to add and now
since 2014 he has been the head of the
European Commission in catchman in turn
the Prime Minister of the state well
he's also been around for a long time in
his role he is he's always been with the
green party he's the first Green Prime
Minister that this state has seen and
he's not always been in line with the
party line but that makes him popular
amongst the citizens of this state now I
would like to ask both of the gentlemen
to join me on stage so we can start with
a short introduction question in a
second
right choose your seat somebody on the
right somebody on the left not a
political statement here all right now
let's start with the Prime Minister mr.
gochman what are the topics that keep
you up at night right now when you think
of Europe and what do you think is what
are the topics that touched the state in
particular well I would mention three
things the first thing is something that
has come up in the speeches and that's
the old story of Europe as a space of
freedom peace and prosperity I think
this is a story that we have to keep
telling you just have to take a look
around the world this is not something
that's to be taken for granted it's not
something we can take for granted and if
you think back to the wars that we have
on this continent but also if we look at
the prosperity on this continent I mean
just yesterday I I read a book with my
wife on a part of the state that is
called who and so on and we are now
Buhl's
60 years old and the increase in
prosperity over the past 70 years is
unbelievable if you try to think back
what the life was like in a village back
then and then well refreshing that story
retelling that story over and over again
that's important we can must not forget
about that story the freedom that we're
experiencing is not something to be
taken for granted is something we need
to fight for and see especially in times
of right-wing populism and then how do
we
defend ourselves in terms of politics in
terms of economics against old powers
such as your as the US and China I've
just come back from California from
Silicon Valley if we look at the five
largest IT companies if we look at their
portfolio how they expand their
portfolio if we look at the developments
on the Chinese side which are similar
how are you ever going to compete with
that as a national state that's an
illusion the ginormous amounts of money
that a venture capitalists can invest in
a start-up that's an order of magnitude
we are never going to achieve so the
only answer can be a European answer and
then one of the big challenges looking
back at Silicon Valley looking at
artificial intelligence as part of the
digital revolution that is going to be
the decisive factor where we are going
to see gigantic development in all parts
of our lives huge sums of money are
being pumped into the hot spots of
research so for example that is another
area where Europe needs to get ready and
get off the ground it's been mentioned
by the European Minister McConnell had a
great idea which was about the European
universities I mean we're working on
that already to have the European
universities connected but if we look at
the budgets
we will never be able to compete even
though we are fairly wealthy state it's
another issue where only my European
cooperation will be able to compete for
the topics such as migration climate
change once again California we have a
cooperation that has shown that the US
are not just Trump they are more than
Trump and that's something that only
Europe can do as part of the euro stuff
the Paris climate agreement so these are
the news stories we need to tell we need
to develop because every nation-state
for themselves will be completely
overwhelmed they will not have the
facilities they will not have the power
to change anything I think the Brits
will be rather surprised when they
realize what they're faced with after
that horrendous decision they made I
think those are the three key aspects
freedom and prosperity how are we going
to assert ourselves in that struggle for
power amongst the the big powers and
what are the tasks that we can only
solve as Europe and not as an individual
national state thank you so much mr.
coachman
so mr. Yong chol what are your topics
what is something you would like to
suggest to your successor next year as a
task well he needs to well just get a
grasp and take a look around well to
start out with I would like to say hello
to people from Freiburg somebody
somebody told me that when I go
somewhere to give a speech I have to say
I'm glad to be there well tonight that's
actually true because I like the city
it's not just the warmest city of Europe
but also because the people are warm at
heart I know this region very well
between Christmas and New Year I always
go on holiday to vintage art and just
round the corner from here now you're
going to have a lot of people following
you around there next time you go yeah
but people in tartan they're always very
very kind because you know I know I know
myself better than they know me so but I
like the Black Forest - lift off
Mountain hint at certain and of course
firework I like that city and I would
like to ask the Lord Mayor to say hello
to the fight book citizens from me
because I really really like them I can
basically just continue where where was
that Kuchma stopped there's so much talk
about Europe so many things are being
said that are untrue we are tired of
European of being Europeans we are not
happy about our achievements but then we
have achieved so much and many things
that we have achieved we take for
granted especially the most important
thing that we've achieved that's peace
on a continent that's being taken for
granted as a matter of fact
and when I talk to younger people we
don't talk about war in peas and
tragical dilemma I do it anyways because
young people need to know where we've
come from my father was a german soldier
in the Second World War because he was
forced by Hitler to join the vemma the
German army now as a former prime
minister of Luxembourg I am in firework
and it's completely normal for me to be
here and talk to all of you and that was
not normal 70 years ago because
Luxembourg was occupied by the Nazis
back then and one of the great
achievements of my dad in his life is
that I am actually German friendly and I
was raised that way that is an enormous
achievement because the people who
returned from the front
we were returned from the concentration
camps to their destroyed villages and
they developed a political program never
again war that we're stopped profiting
from today that is an enormous
achievement of the generation of the
great war of the Second World War we are
just not realizing it and that's why I
keep saying it even tonight it's a great
achievement
now first of all I would like for us to
change our discourse about Europe I
don't want to split into pro Europeans
and people who are against Europe the
world isn't black and white we have to
talk even to the skepticism not
everybody is against Europe they're not
opponents a lot of people have a lot of
questions and you can't just put them
aside because we just cannot be bothered
to answer them there is justified
criticism of the European Union and we
have to face that however we cannot just
blindly follow the populist if you
follow the populist and people do that
especially a lot of people in the
classical political parties you become a
populist yourself if you follow them we
have to fight the nationalism we have to
fight the patriotism we have to fight
the populist then we have to do that
massively
and then we need a lot more solidarity
within Europe the refugee crisis showed
us that there is a lack of solidarity in
Europe a refugee who arrives somewhere
in Europe doesn't just arrive in a
country he or she arrives in Europe and
that's why we need to find European
answers to the refugee challenge and
then for us we have to find the right
measure of things the right level 25
people of the of the population of
Jordan are refugees there are 70 million
internal refugees in Africa internally
displaced people
so the refugee integration that we have
to do that's a joke if you compare it to
what other countries in the world have
to struggle with have to contend with
so that's why we also need more
solidarity with Africa 2050 we're going
to have 2.5 billion million Africans
billion Africans 10 million young
Africans join the year the African
employment market every year but it's a
non-existent employment market because
we're not investing enough instead of
fighting the causes of the European
refugee crisis instead of talking and
talking and talking about it we have to
fight the causes where they are and that
doesn't work through doing good things
and donating money that's something that
works by investing there that's by
creating jobs in Africa investing in
Africa because there's only one world
and that's not a world that belongs just
to us it belongs to everyone also the
people in Africa that's why we need to
do more there and when I'm talking about
solidarity we also need internal
solidarity what really bugs me is that
the social dimension of the European
Union was almost ignored until today
if you can if you think you can get
Europe on track without dealing with the
needs of the working population you are
mistaken people people who work simple
jobs they're not more stupid than the
elite so we need to tackle the topic of
the social Europe much more intensely
and then we need a capability to act on
the international on the global
political in the global particular arena
we are diplomatic dwarves in global
politics I call that very politic fish
guide I've coined that term and then we
need to find majorities in global
politics we're sitting in New York and
we we look very smart but we don't have
a lot to say about a lot of topics
because there's just no unity within
Europe when it's about human rights in
China we want to defend them when it's
about to talk about Chinese maneuvers in
the South China Sea if it's about
assessing them we can't do it because
one of the member state looks at it
differently than the majority if you
don't want to just talk but if you
actually want to act upon what you say
if we actually want to influence what
happens in the world then in terms of
foreign policy we have to act in a more
unified fashion than we are doing now we
keep thinking that we can now go back to
diplomatics of national states but you
cannot have a Europe without the
national states of course but if we try
to if we're just if there's just so few
of us then we have to stand together I
talked to the to the minister president
earlier on about Galileo
there are lots of satellites in the in
space there are 400 million users of the
European satellite system do you really
believe that any state by itself could
have put 26 satellites in space what
looks and work wouldn't have been able
to that's for sure and Luxembourg is not
a small country
because I reminded the British Prime
Minister that there are only two big
countries in Luxembourg the Grand Duchy
of Luxembourg its Great Britain and the
Grand Duchy so very soon there'll only
be one great country in Europe well
thank you so much dialogue requires
structures and of course the structures
are also present here tonight I
mentioned earlier on that this afternoon
we already had a workshop of randomly
selected citizens from this region and
they have dealt with a lot of these
topics very intensely I have looked into
it in great detail and they are going to
voice to questions to start out with to
also give you an opportunity to come up
with questions that's all you all of you
in the audience here tonight and maybe
start looking for the microphones they
are placed around the room and the
quicker we can do that the more
questions will be heard tonight the more
answers you'll hear tonight and the
shorter and the more precise your
questions are the more questions can be
heard and answered now I would like to
start with the first question from the
group of the people who were here for
the workshop this afternoon I'd like to
ask that person to step up to the
microphone I would like to add that
maybe everyone could introduce
themselves which actually reminds me
that I haven't done that I'm the one
person who hasn't introduced themselves
my name is Thomas Hauser and I'm the
chief editor of the budget site or
newspaper in five work well if we go
[Applause]
my name is Louise I'm a shy but he's
America's my name and I'm this box
person would you please move a bit
closer to microphone Lewis emerges my
name I'm a spokesperson of the theme
education which both of you also touched
upon to a certain extent our debate was
about recognition of training and
education standards within the European
Union especially for educators both
professionally and not at a professional
level language education in primary
schools to certain extent under the
aspect of acquiring language skills but
also acquiring cultural aspects and also
cohesion within the European Union
European networking was more important
aspect students using inter a ticket
youth exchange programs that should be
expended and also promoted but also
repeat our work of the European Union
now let me ask my first question how can
the European idea be implanted early on
in schools and what are the tangible
plans to do that at let's say a federal
level or a level of the federal state or
even at the level of the European Union
a big thank you now the second question
please hello everybody my against live
eyes my name and my group dealt with
social injustice let me ask my question
right awayy social justice that is
growing in the European Union how can it
be combat it and how can we avoid that
people use tax evasion within the
European Union
[Applause]
to the mercantile mr. younger would you
like to answer the first part I think
the biggest contribution that national
and regional education systems can make
to better understanding the European
Union is if we had multilingual tea in
the primary schools in all of the
European Union may I use Luxembourg as
an example
apart from letsa birch everybody learns
German French and English plus Latin
Spanish old Greek or Portuguese once not
ridiculous because once you speak all
the five languages nobody will make fun
of you
you know these languages in Luxembourg
that's comparatively easy because our
neighbors are the Germans and the French
and they do never use their common sense
they do not want to learn let's approach
so what would we have to do which asset
you learn French in German and master it
as well as our own language and whoever
speaks every languages will find a way
into the European culture by knowing
that language alone and therefore we
tell everybody in Europe don't only
learn your own language learning another
two or three foreign languages so that
they don't stay foreign to you that is
why we need an intensification of our
efforts to mutually recognized national
certificates and diploma at a European
level this will open up new
opportunities for young people of course
in Turei will help them that by also
adding new funds to what we have in
terms of Erasmus funds today
will we be able to allow young Europeans
to acquire academic degrees in other
countries so we'll increase that front
by eighty percent in the next period
until 2020 whenever young people go and
study abroad
lots of prejudices will not even come to
life that will come to life if they stay
within their own countries and therefore
it is important to also change and live
in other countries or other regions
it's found in women in five-o studio
well actually I said it in Fryeburg no I
want it I wanted to study German but
then Luxembourg's Ministry of Education
that don't do that they told me listen
you'll better become a lawyer then I
didn't come to fiber but I went to
Strasbourg but we still don't have
enough people to teach Germany
Luxembourg so I should have come to
Freiburg instead mr. gochman anything to
add or would you rather like to answer
the question about social politics we
have European intra connections here but
it's still national law today first of
all talk about the first question
education degrees or certificates that's
what happened in the Bologna process but
some still find it difficult to do that
because people like what they call de
plume engineer in German an engineering
diploma if you translate it literally
but the process has been initiated when
looking at the dual education system
then that's something that doesn't even
exist in other countries this dual
education system only exists in
german-speaking countries austria
switzerland our countries everybody else
says we'd also love to have it but it is
deeply rooted in our education systems
and it's not so easy
well what one talking about Erasmus
students exchange programs there's not
only relates to students but this
opportunity should also be given to
other people what you have to see the
brexit means that a lot of money is
missing in a European year in 80 million
approximately and to add to the Erasmus
funds against that background is the
right decision I can't but agree with
the President of the European Commission
it is one of the most important
questions that we have today and third a
European University is intended to do
more than just having an exchange
European University here at the Upper
Rhine means that during the same week
you attend so I'm gonna hear a class
there a program and the address a city
and therefore you need excellent
transportation so that you can reach the
other universities within an hour's time
approximately which will be something
for which we need this railway
connection between Freiburg and climb
out so it has become very tangible for
the students that it can really go
directly to the different countries now
social politics I think it's a question
about minimums that minimum standards
currently we talk about that in refugee
politics if what refugees get differs
widely in the various countries then
it's normal that Dublin will not become
reality we can only talk about minimums
related to all these questions it's
difficult enough to agree on a minimum
so these are extremely difficult
questions to tackle however we have to
tackle them because if the living
conditions in the European Union
diverged that much then this idea of
cohesion is very very difficult to
implement well we have freedom of
movement in the European Union we have
very very strong movements in that
direction therefore it's so important to
ensure that we at least agree on minimum
standards may add that committee who set
up the increase of the Erasmus funds had
the plan that it's not enough to just
bring together students but that people
from different origins have to be have
to come together and have an exchange in
November 2017 that's happened in
Gothenburg
minimum standards in the social area
were agreed euro is more than economy
although the euro and economy are
important but the social situation on
our continent is of utmost important and
we need minimum standards without the
same level of social benefits well
that's difficult but the same
instruments should be used at least
minimum wages should be fixed the same
rules should apply now we did that when
we talked about the second regulation
when I start at the time that they said
don't touch that because that low in the
end up in trouble and such at the
beginning it seems impossible until it's
done and the social thing social
endeavor has to be started although it
seems impossible today are you questions
answer it do you think they've been
answered well I'm not very happy yet
constraining the language skills and the
cultural aspects of Education mr.
Juncker you gave a good answer
what happens at the level of the
different countries federal states but
the federal state of that button bag is
not really in line with that and time a
teacher and therefore that matters so
much to me acquiring language skills is
something that is a little bit missed
out well I'd like to help you to really
save the honor of your federal state
because in mine it's wide but not as
wide as you may think the education
system in baden-württemberg seems to be
one of the best of all of Europe well I
didn't really want to voice thoughts
about that I don't doubt it
I do apologize that my answer didn't
really match your question well I think
we understood what you mean but I think
this is something that you have to talk
about the representative of the federal
state let me answer now when we said the
first foreign language to be taught at
school along the upper Ryan there was a
lot of resistance by the parents don't
forget about it
they warned you that their children be
taught English so that was against the
resistance of the parents that we held
on to that second it's true foreign
language classes will now only be
offered starting from grade three in
primary school well that's a question of
resources and whether it is really worth
it it is a question of funds use of
funds and benefits that you rate from it
and that there the cost-benefit ratio
was just too bad
everybody knows that we have tremendous
difficulties finding enough primary
school teachers we have a lack of
teachers
so there are deficits then the question
is what matters more I talked to the
French regional president recently their
experiences very similar actually they
don't do that any longer in 25 percent
of the schools they offer bilingual
education and that is really efficient
that is worth it
that is when young children will learn a
foreign language but offering but a few
hours per week is not really worth it I
mean there are no hard facts there is no
hard evidence but there indicators
telling you that what children
learned in grade 1 and 2 while it is
something that it forgotten two weeks
after that again so the use of resources
because you have to do a lot to really
bring them with the teaching media they
have to be able to operate a smart phone
and and and but you can't just say and
and and you sometimes also have to ask
what you can take away so the question
of foreign language classes here we more
or less all agree the point is right how
can we do it to reach a desired effect
so that Indian you don't just do
something for doing something thank you
I think that mattre has been recognized
and also debated in full any further
questions where are the people from the
audience would love to ask questions
please feel free to ask Peter Parker
focus my name and try come from very
high up in the Black Forest Mountains
and only very recently I went to the
three country Museum in LA so please
keep it brief please keep your question
brave where is the speaker where are you
Oh up there okay I didn't see that
corner yes fantastic now very brave a
hypothetical question it is but if let's
assume the rich people in bridging have
another referendum and then decide to
stay in the European Union
what will the response of mr. younger be
will he say well the European Union we
don't want that that is not a very
serious if you say this or one time yes
and the other time now and what would
you do if they said yes we will stay
[Applause]
I'm a member of the Action Group Z
brokered the C bridge we handed letter
to your to your staff outside we hope
that you that you get it it's about
saving people in the Mediterranean Sea
I'm glad to hear what you said about
situation of the refugees and that you
mentioned that problems with the number
of refugees there are actually
ridiculous if you compare it to what
countries in Africa are struggling with
and the question that we have is the
following we you look back and that's
something that I can identify with you
looked back at the situation after the
war and we didn't just have developments
regarding the peace but also the
Commission European Commission for human
rights and that's another response to
the catastrophe of the second one first
and second world war at the beginning of
the century so as part of the European
treaties the European Union agrees to
the European Convention for Human Rights
but we are not respecting the human
rights right now could you please keep
your question short says the speaker
well Italy took were refugees back to
Libya and they were taken to court for
that so the question is what can we do
against it and what can you do against
it as a president of the Commission or
what can you do against it as a prime
minister of baden-württemberg what can
we do against European countries
disrespecting the basic values the
codified values of European conventions
and that they're ignoring human rights
right then we have a question over there
on the right yeah I'm a Frenchman I've
been in Germany for 30 years there's a
lot of echo in the hall we can barely
hear you can you hear me better now a
little bit uh you know a glass yeah I'm
a Frenchman I've been in Germany for
thirty years now I'm
how to be a European I have a question
for mr. young car 270 million euros of
fundings are not being used in the
European Union and we cannot get
countries to use these funds that's a
lot of money we have heard there
problems with education you want to
invest you want to solve some of the
problems is it a problem of the
structures of the European Union the
structures are the right ones for our
day and age have we adapted to the speed
of the development of a world in general
is that something that we can solve why
cannot use the countries that are
available funds of the European Union
and now the fourth question from the
gentleman in the back and then we're
going to start answering some of these
questions and then we'll take another
round of questions
- Hollander is my name mr. young car you
said a sentence that I've found to be
very true
the Euro scepticism eat also we need to
have a dialogue with them I know a lot
of them who don't feel at home in the
European Union because they feel they
are excluded in terms of language and in
terms of culture and that is not just
because if they look for something on
the website of the Commission for
example the reports of the Commission
because they only find them in English
and that's also got to do with the
symbolic image of the Commission that
are portrays to the outside is only
available in English and in French up to
the year 2012 if there were TV images
from the press room of the Commission up
to 2012 the press room was actually
labeled in all languages of the European
Union and now it's only English and
French so why doesn't the Commission do
it the way the European Parliament does
it so presenting themselves to the
European Union
in all the language of the European
Union the Commission could do that as
well thank you so mr. Janka that's a
question that was addressed to you
well I have my doubts whether that's
true in every detail as you present it
so passionately here because we make a
great effort to communicate in all the
official languages so at every press
conference I speak at least three
languages and other comes ours they also
use the different languages and they
publish in different languages and
they're available in all the languages
of the European Union's so I cannot
quite understand why you feel and you
think that we're only communicating in
two or three languages so that's just
not the case the immediate communication
is in two or three working languages but
after that everything is translated and
that by the way is there's quite a
budget factor you people complain about
the administrative costs and all the red
tape and the European Commission and you
know people need to use the money and
use up the budgets and so much of the
money goes to the administration people
complain about that but that's partly
due to the fact that we have everything
translated into several languages all
the official languages of the European
Union we have the largest and the best
interpreter service of the entire world
so labeling the press centre that
doesn't cost a lot of money does it well
the labels I don't know what languages
they're in because I am actually at the
rostrum and I don't read what's on the
walls but I'll check it well but let's
keep this short and in the dialogues on
the on the details we were also talking
about brexit and the Seabrook initiative
and human rights
well let's talk about saving people at
sea
I think we should not part with minimum
solidarity if you're actually if you're
actually in the state of distress at sea
then you need to be saved international
maritime law applies and that's not
something that we can wriggle out of as
a European Union no matter how hard we
try it's not possible but what I would
like to see is that if people in Greece
or in Italy of people strand their that
other Europeans would also look into how
these people are dealt with
[Applause]
it's not be about the geographic
location of the country it's about
compassion and that's going to require a
lot of talks and a lot of difficult
talks and we need to convince the others
of that as a commission when it comes to
refugee aid in 2015 we made lots of
proposals how we could do that how we
could distribute the refugees to the
different countries and so on and so
forth if all the member countries would
have gone along with our proposals then
we would have really seen less suffering
and a lot of people wouldn't have had to
die looking away is not a way to have
tackle our future we have to look at
what's happening and we have to find
solutions but we also have to talk to
the refugees if you come to Europe I'm
not talking about economic refugees but
also those but Europe is not the harbour
for all the economic refugees of the
world that's something that we all have
to accept I don't like accepting it but
we have to if people if refugees arrive
in Greece or in Italy and you try to
redistribute them then we cannot have
the refugees determine where they would
like to go we had an agreement in the
European Union once upon a time that we
are going to take refugees from Greece
and transport them to other countries
but they all want to come to Germany so
the Luxembourg government that's not my
government because I'm not the big guy
there anymore the Luxembourg government
said we're going to accept 50 refugees
and that plane remained empty up until
the day when the Luxembourg ins said
well we are the neighboring country of
Germany and then we didn't have enough
planes anymore that's not possible
either the refugees don't get to
determine where they want to go the
European governments get to decide to
regulate the flow of refugees so that we
can handle
[Applause]
so that was the basic question on the
development oh there was a there was a
basic question on whether the structure
of the institution's is still up to date
if I remember that correctly and the
other question was what's going to
happen with brexit if the Brits were to
come up with a bright idea to maybe stay
well I spend a lot of time with the
brexit but not tonight
because brexit is a question of the past
praxis is undoing European history I
like to deal with the future I like to
deal with the people who want Europe now
we are right in the middle of these
difficult brexit negotiations and I'm
totally for finding a good way to
cooperate with the Brits as friends we
keep to need to keep the civil serious
rap from the European Parliament here we
sometimes feel like that well that the
Brits feel we are leaving them but it's
the other way around they are the ones
who are leaving won't mr coachman the
Germans would probably love to take the
Brits back if they were to change their
minds yeah for sure I think that would
be the smallest problem if they if they
were to do that I think the Labour Party
with a great majority now decided to
have a new referendum whether that's
going to happen or not I do not know but
those are questions that only the Brits
will be able to resolve if they wanted
to stay in the European Union I think it
would be not a very big problem for us
what I really regrets as mister Janka in
in the context of brexit
is that there were there was no real
brexit campaign in terms of actual
information in Great Britain the people
are finding out now
also British ministers and ministers on
the continent they're finding out now
how many questions that actually poses
all the things that we need to resolve
so if I start to even ask myself what's
going to happen to the 250,000 dogs and
cats which leave the European continent
every year towards right now right now
they just passed through customs you
know all these dogs and cats coming to
mainland Europe every year I mean there
are lots of people in Europe who just
want people to people in animals to just
cross borders but I think we're just
going to have four day quarantine and if
you want to go to Brittany for eight
days for vacation for the holidays then
maybe you need to leave the dog or the
cat at home but maybe you'll just stay
home all together what's going to happen
to air traffic in Europe if everything
goes wrong British planes will not be
able to land on the European continent
people don't know that somebody should
have told them beforehand somebody
should have really told people this
beforehand so something you wanted to
add mr. coachman no then we'll have the
next set of questions I have three
people at the microphone here in front
and the fourth person all the way in the
back I think you've already asked your
question right oh please get started up
here in the front good evening Patrick
she cries my name I would like to know
where you would like to see the European
Union in 20 years what would be your
dream are we going to return into the
United States of Europe or European
Republic how far would you like the
integration process to go are we going
to have a joint military and social
policy or what do you think where where
it might make sense to to stop
integration well I'm really opposed to
the European Union becoming a republic
because otherwise we would have to
disband the Grand Duchy and I wouldn't
want that for the great Grand Duke or
his successor I'm against pretending as
if the European Union was about to
become a state I'm opposed to trying to
become the United States of Europe
people love to be citizens of
baden-württemberg they love to be people
from the Black Forest they feel like
they're from freesia they're from
Luxembourg they're from Flanders
felonious people don't want to be lumped
together they don't want everything to
be destroyed that is of regional
national significance that is never
going to happen we are never going to be
the United States of Europe based on the
example of the United States of America
never
okay okay we were going to collect
questions what we are going to have more
members the Western Balkans they're
going to join us eventually but only if
they fulfill the conditions I'm opposed
to just enlarging the European Union and
just saying goodbye to all the criteria
you have to be ready for it and we have
to be ready to take you in and that's
just not the case right now all right
now for you please evening your hunger
takur from the natural protect nature
Protection Association Germany I'm in
charge of agriculture in the state all
right now my question for tonight it's
more or less a personal question it's
about agriculture policy so millions of
euros 87 million euros are spent every
year on agricultural policy that's 38 of
the European 38 percent of the European
budget and the goals of the European
Union were not achieved with that over
the past few years so sustainability and
the protection of the environment
and so on and so forth we have lots of
problems with biodiversity in protection
of the species problems with with
drinking water lots and lots of
fertilizer being found in in the ground
and so on and so forth now my question
mr. president Janka you said you look to
the future and you want to shape this
future and you get to make choices that
will affect the agriculture policy 20 to
20 21 21 2020 2021 so for those 7 years
what are you going to do to improve the
agricultural policy we all live for from
the soil from the water from the variety
of the species that we have and what are
you going to do to to keep that to
protect that and if you look at the 58
million euro if you divide that by
European citizens that comes down to 140
euros per persons and that's excluding
all the other budget on state and
regional levels so what would you do
with the taxes I mean you pay
taxes with those 114 euros to do more
for nature could you please get to the
point that was the second question
okay well then that should be used Mr
Cashman has already answered that
question and sent us a brief statement
if there was anything you would like to
add feel free to do so right now or
maybe do that in writing if you like so
the EU policy agricultural politics and
114 euros
thank you so much well not not all the
58 million euros are spent on
agricultural politics I think well you
get to answer in just a second we're
just going to listen to the to the two
questions well it's very kind of you to
allow me to answer that question I just
kind of remember all the questions well
alright then I'll remind you I'll remind
you where necessary how much is the
European Union spending for agriculture
I don't remember well I just said it and
you were going to remind me about the
questions all right please the next
question
good-evening cattlemen who rises from
the Center for European politics here
from Freiburg a brief question do we
have to worry about the populist
government in Italy about them plunging
us into the next crises in Europe and in
the European area
well we just had a quick answer on the
stage but never mind mr. president
professor Sheila the former Minister for
economics said in the 70s the euro can
only work if within Europe we have
unified economic and financial policy
and if I think of Italy but also of
other countries then there's no trace of
that to be found anywhere how do you see
that similar well if we all answer them
that way then we're going to have a lot
of questions tonight thanks please I
teach church history at the University
mr. Janka I think it's great that as a
perspective for Europe you have such a
global perspective that you've opened up
for us and that you don't just say we
have to look at Europe and make sure
that we're OK in terms of finances or
that internally everything is fine in
terms of social cohesion but that we
also have to look at our values and that
we have to promote them globally the
aspect you mentioned was foreign
politics I wonder whether that's enough
and if not before we start working on a
joint foreign policy we should maybe do
a homework in in the world so were
colonial powers in Europe I have to pay
debt so I still need to pay their debts
where we need to make sure that if we
realize that due to our lifestyle we are
affecting the lifestyle in other
countries where worsening the situation
there that we look at all that before we
look at foreign policy shouldn't part of
our homework also be that we stand up as
Europeans
and say that for global companies we
need a global legal system and a global
social system so that these large groups
of companies are forced to stick to the
laws to abide by the laws and to pay
taxes isn't that something we need to do
first we start answering the questions
now but agriculture and environment here
I'd like to accept also the question
from the workshop group this afternoon
who dealt with that subject we can
Oman's the name good evening and I'm the
spokesperson who talked about
Environment and climate change this
afternoon especially against the
background of the climate change
agreement Paris climate change agreement
we talked about the fact whether these
are global agreements but that they are
not binding but voluntary we wondered
what it is no European wide agreement on
that with binding targets and what kind
of sanctions one could take if these
agreements are not complied with we also
feel that a European agreement is
definitely necessary because Germany
cannot on its own succeed in getting out
of coal
one of the biggest forests in Germany is
being cut down currently in order to
save coal harvesting
[Applause]
while cutting down all the trees in the
Humber forest humbie you'll live well
that's a political demonstration to go
with all of that so - over to Yuma
simcha well these were twelve questions
altogether I counted them all of them
but now I have to rush through these
questions and and then people will not
gain an insight but will not be very
happy because I cannot really fully
answer these questions not to the extent
that the Oscars would like have me
answer them let me start with Karl
Schiller he said something in this 1970s
that he couldn't know at the time that's
why he could not say it at the beginning
of the 70s in the early 70s when he was
young and strong and nobody talked about
the Euro at the time because that debate
only started in the late 1970s but one
point is true in the long run a single
currency will not survive if you don't
intertwine the economies and the
financial policies and we are working on
it in a European group in the European
Commission we really try our best every
day we take new resolutions decisions
letters of intent Ziegler ations of
intense but that is not really what the
paper it's written on it doesn't really
make sense that one says a anti
addresses B if we're talking about the
same currency so we are onion door
actively working on it now let's talk
about a chilling brief question I just
wanted to say that I'm able to answer
very briefly so that's why I answer when
you said Italy and and I now summarized
in my own words and I said yes danger
yes Italian government
the away from the path of virtue that we
had to coordinate everything in our
budgetary policy and so on and so forth
we are the midst of discussions with the
Italian government and by the 15th of
October the member countries will have
to hand in their budgets to Brussels and
then we'll look whether it's acceptable
or not it seems as if but you can't
really say so yet I read about it I read
about it in the press that this will not
be the case so that'll be quite exciting
however I would not wish that after
having really been able to cope with the
Greek crisis we'll end up in the same
crisis in Italy again one such crisis
has been enough and if you tell me Italy
one's further special treatment that
would mean the end of the euro so you
have to be very strict and just while
cutting down German forests is something
I will not interfere with I do not
really know enough about it and be I
learned that wherever national
governments are responsible the European
Commission should not start shooting I
have my own opinion if I were to tell
you that opinion fifty percent of the
population would be happy in the other
fifty percent would be unhappy so it's
none of my business
now I'm paid rather well for keeping my
mouth shut sometimes
and that's why I will not interfere I
talked about foreign policy while that
is a collective term it's that external
policy in a diplomatic or a most very
sense of the word but I also talked
about Africa I mean there are regions
that can be somehow be covered so I'm
very much in favor of dealing with the
question what makes a way of life such
that other people the world will suffer
because of it because even today 37
countries in Africa can export their
products tax-free into the European
Union in artisan tariffs free customs
free into the European Union people say
well it mustn't be that you charge
customs tariffs on products from Africa
that's not true at all because 37
countries consent into Europe without
customs tariffs
so we are free trade between Europe and
Africa and I suggested that to the
European Parliament just recently we
need fair and equal connections between
African Europe and not a commando in
Europe over Africa that would be wrong
because that would be a universe
dramatic Universal mistake so if we
behaved as if we were the Masters of
Africa which we are not
[Applause]
winfried I hope you won't get bored
because I still have to tackle the
agriculture question well that was a
whole essay so I'm very much in favor
that in the future when designing the
European agricultural fund will ensure
first that small operations will
primarily be supported and not large
operations well the financial proposals
of the Commission for agriculture for
the next seven years proved that the
beneficiaries of agriculture support
otherwise would be the Queen of England
because she has one of the smallest
agriculture operations in the European
Union we have to do away with that
ecological sustainable agricultural
policy has become established in Europe
and that we have to focus on small farms
less than 46 hector's that is the size
that we determined during the
agricultural reform that has to be
expanded a little bit but we don't want
large agricultural factories in Europe
rural areas live mainly on small farms
family manage operations we should pay
attention to that well if it be so kind
now to each other today 100,000 farmers
in Barberton back please spread the word
then I'd be listening to you but not
otherwise know agriculture and
Environmental Protection
I guess you'd also love to talk about
that well I really advertise that
when talking to Missy uncle we have to
be more sustainable however so far we
haven't been able to achieve that over
proportional funds cut in the second
pillar the first pillar our direct
payments to the farm is there simply
given money for farming land the second
pillar it's more or less a compensation
for environmental measures that they
take and in the second pillar funds are
cut over proportionally nobody can say
that this is good and the third pillar
we should do that in a more aggressive
way small farms should get more but
because they are such more ecological
they care for the environment much more
than the others but we're talking about
a timeline of seven years and beyond so
everything is determined for that time
we have of course also possibilities in
Germany but even there we won't find a
consensus just thinking about the
different federal state such as
mecklenburg-vorpommern where we find
these large farms and these are fetters
say so don't do that well financially so
even in Germany we don't find a
consensus very soon there'll be another
meeting with Commissioner Hogan and our
Minister for the agriculture dragna
where I'll mention that again to make
agriculture more sustainable has to be
our priority we have a dramatic decline
in diversity
the reason is mainly in this
industrialized agriculture we're not
talking about peanuts we are talking
about the basic structures of our
ecological system these are really
alarming signals we cannot pretend we
cannot say that we have to really exert
pressures to change the situation not a
question before we support Africa there
is rather the question where do you win
exports come in will be there not exert
pressure on the small farm subsistence
agriculture
these are dramatical questions that you
have to ask yourselves climate
protection the European Union has the
right instrument at heart which is
emission trade but emission trade
doesn't work because there are too many
certificates being traded meaning that
prices have become such that you don't
can that you cannot do some for steering
I mean the prices are increasing
slightly but actually we have a
macroeconomic instrument which would be
extremely effective if it were to work
but that's always the case social
ecological market economy doesn't work
without the state it doesn't work
without the European Union the question
how many certificates are allowed to be
trade it is something that has to be
decided and so far it just doesn't work
I'm not talking about an agreement
because I think the Paris climate change
agreement is a breakthrough but the
instruments that we have should be used
properly
because in addition to emission trade we
could add traffic and other things and
then we'd have to write instrument so
everything that we have should work one
should use them otherwise we'll lose
trust and if we lose trust will never
gain it again it's quite difficult to
expand the European Union we see that
when we look at the refugee crisis there
are entire nations that flatly refuse to
accept the one single refugees and the
contingents that we have should be
workable
[Applause]
the big of T was now taking a glance at
my watch I realized two things mr.
younger was right it's always
dissatisfying because there's always
more questions than we have chance to
answer secondly now before you make your
closing statements I can only admit the
last question from the group because mr.
Janka in a few minutes we'll have to
leave us unfortunately my name is
Yasmine attea
I represent the group who dealt with
migration and integration we had very
controversial the employment market
exchange across borders and European
immigration law and then we did a
democratic vote on which question to ask
you which is the following what are the
actual measures to fight the causes for
people fleeing their countries are being
implemented right now how are they being
financed and what ideas you have for the
future I have taken a democratic vote
that I have the following answer to
offer to you tonight first of all
fighting the causes for people fleeing
their countries that brings me back to
the topic of Africa but not just Africa
I am appalled that so many member states
of the European Union's over the past
few years have decreased the amount of
funding for developmental eight instead
of increasing the funds we are taken
away budgets from African continent and
that is wrong if we want to have a
chance in the future the European Union
is the biggest provider of funds when
it's about Economic Cooperation and
developmental aid we are providing more
funds than Australia the US and Canada
put together but within Europe there are
only two countries who are paying more
than 0.7 percent of their economic power
and that's Sweden and Luxembourg both of
them are beyond 1 percent the other
countries are far below 1 percent the
Germans are paying just to mention that
just so we don't start protesting I
don't I don't even want to mention what
the Germans are paying embarassingly
high of course they're not you could do
a lot more
we have investment program for
investments outside Europe of 44 billion
euros we started that program two years
ago to be able to create jobs on-site
and to be able to invest on-site and the
Member States
two years ago promised that they would
add to the 44 million year billion euros
that come from the European budget they
would add another 44 billion and that
doesn't happen we have a trust fund for
Africa with the with the same with the
same target of 2.5 billions the member
states were supposed to pay their share
they didn't do it and with the
contribution from Germany of several
hundred million euros we up the volume
to 1.4 billion euros but to pretend that
nothing was happening is not right
there's of course it's not sufficient
it's not enough but the European
developmental aid it's never centralised
it's never coordinated the Commission
does one thing the Member States does
something else then we've got the German
states they do their own thing most of
them have their own developmental aid
program but what we're lacking is a
centralized coordination center that
would that would decide or maybe
negotiate what's the best way to
distribute these funds and that's a
dilemma it's a dilemma that I face every
week if a country
that cooperates in terms of economics
with Europe suddenly disregards human
rights altogether if there's a dictator
in charge do we then stop the payments
altogether do we keep them at the level
where they are and the simple answer is
we'll just discontinue our developmental
aid but who do we hit with that measure
do we hit the dictator or does that
affect the people who were profiting
from these programs who could still
profit from these programs and those are
not simple questions and of course these
are questions we're asking ourselves
within Europe as well if somebody
doesn't if somebody doesn't stick by the
rules if somebody decides to do their
own thing like Italy is doing right now
I don't give a damn about Europe I'm in
charge of Italy and not of Europe what
do we do do we simply look away or do we
start to come up with ideas the things
are never quite as simple as the
newspapers put them the Peugeot Sudoku
Nihon comma in evaluation scientific
potential Avenue hajdu t t hepatic the
new nouvelle technology proper whose
alternative existence suit Avila obeah
VAR permit to the favelas elite read
more I thought of Aloha Judy attack
silly since the 60s but for decades we
deny this fact we call them guest
workers
that was a big lie a lie for a lifetime
we were lying about it but also the
people who will come in here lie to
themselves about who they thought we
were you know we're just gonna come here
make some money and then we're gonna go
back home afterwards
now it'll be interesting to see whether
the coalition in Berlin will succeed in
separating the refugee regime and the
immigration regime because it's a
constant source for worries and for
concerns and it also helps populism so
who do we prosecute who's being
prosecuted if somebody is not prosecuted
in the home country they need to go back
but that can only work if we also have
an immigration regime that would say
people can legally immigrated into this
country I've just been to Canada and I
had them explain it to me in great
detail how they do it how they go about
it and it's a great role model basically
so there is a positive positive attitude
towards immigration and of course after
that entire culture of welcome there was
a shift within Europe and if we can't or
in Germany and if we can't get it done
in our own country we can't the European
Union to get it done so first of all we
need to put together an immigration law
in our own country which would make us
an immigration country officially and
then we could stop pretending that we're
not and then we need a refugee Ridge
regime if you're being persecuted in
your home country then you know we'll
protect you and you can stay here and
then we need to find regulations for all
other cases now if people
especially if people start finding jobs
here if people start finding work in
building a life here and then that's
something we need to establish an Europe
a refugee regime European is a continent
that needs immigration and it's a
country it's a continent that is capable
of accepting refugees and if we can
separate those two topics those two
issues then I think things will look up
if you look at the the elections the
upcoming elections in Bavaria everybody
is scared of the AFD Party instead of
showing how to do it right with their
own parties with their own factions and
if we could achieve that within Europe I
think we could also get that done in the
rest of Europe mr. Juncker well on that
on that issue that winfried is touching
upon here I would like to say that on
15th of July 2014 a quarter to 11 in the
European Parliament I suggested I
demanded that we admit as Europeans that
we are a continent of immigration and
that every country needs an immigration
law that makes a coordinated and orderly
immigration into their countries into
Europe possible similar to the Dublin
reform so that we we have the same rules
everywhere so that if people want to
come to Europe they would be faced with
the same rules and regulations no matter
where in Europe they go it's no surprise
that if
if we avoid legal immigration into
Europe which we need that then people
will try to find other ways loopholes of
getting into Europe and if we position
ourselves in the world in a way that a
Europe will have anyone who is being
persecuted in their countries but in
parallel that we will be organizing
parallel immigration paths into Europe
then we will have something to say to
the world that nobody else says the the
Americans are saying goodbye to
multilateralism they have an anti
immigration policy everywhere in the
world
well people thrown upon that they don't
understand it but if if we were to show
a friendly and open-minded face towards
the world and Europe is going to be more
popular anywhere else in the world than
it is in Europe itself thank you so in
closing first of all I would like to
thank you so much president of the
Commission Yuka and prime minister
Richmond for answering our questions
here tonight I would also like to thank
all of you for your commitment and for
your questions in particular thank you
to the group who invested a lot of time
and effort this afternoon a lot of
questions will remain unanswered tonight
a lot of questions we couldn't we just
didn't have the time for but this was to
be expected so I would like to appeal to
all of you to continue to look into
these subjects to ask questions about
these subjects not just tonight if I'm
right mrs. Ella I think on the website
of the state government that that deals
with the project Europe I think there is
a possibility to post questions there
participate in this discussion
and please next year go to the election
make sure that the participation rates
are up and make sure that your friendly
parties get a majority in those
elections thank you so much for coming
tonight mr. young Carr and for
unfortunately we have to say goodbye to
everyone else you're more than welcome
to join us for a little reception
outside the hall have a safe trip home
everyone and hope to see you again
wherever that may be
[Applause]
[Music]
you